[Musique]
le Club climaénergie est une association
loi 1901 caufondée par 550 aneline et
les entreprises du territoire chargé de
réfléchir sur les grands sujets de la
transition écologique et énergétique
nous fêons cette année nos 10 années
d'existence et nous organisons notre 7e
édition de conférence annuelle sur le
thème retour sur la crise énergétique
déccriptage et
perspectives
[Musique]
nous donnons la parole à des
représentants de fédération qui ont été
particulièrement touchés par la crise
mais nous donnons également la parole à
la représentante des entreprises des
petites et moyennes entreprises des
ivelines et à Madame cosmang pour
revenir sur sur le les les les problèmes
des collectivités et notamment des
communes en matière de hausse des prix
de l'énergie au-delà des témoignages que
nous aurons nous donnons et nous avons
souhaité revenir sur la construction des
prix de l'énergie sujet qui est pas
toujours compris et facile à maîtriser
donc à ce titreelà nous interrogerons
les représentants de RTE et de NG sur la
partie gaz et électricité nous donnerons
également la parole à un professeur
d'économie de de Paris saint-clay et
dans la dernière partie de la conférence
nous interrogerons la banque des
territoires sur la partie du financement
de la transition énergétique et Monsieur
amonique et Monsieur cocard sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
sur le territoire et des actions des
territoires en faveur de ces énergiesl
[Musique]
je dirais que jusqu'à demain matin 9h il
est toujours possible d'y participer en
fonction des places disponibles donc en
tout cas vous êtes les
[Musique]
bienvenus